I am so excited to meet our next guest.
She is the director of the critically acclaimed
and award-winning projects like "Selma",
"When they see us", "A wrinkle in time".
She is one of the most prolific filmmakers out there.
I just watched "Colin in Black and White
with complete marvel in my eyes.
Not only did she make last months,
Forbes World's most powerful women,
(audience clapping)
but she's also behind a groundbreaking new CW series
called "Naomi" about a teenage girl
who discovers that she's a superhero.
Not only do I wanna see everything
through Ava DuVernay's lens,
but I can't wait to see what this series is all about.
Oh, please welcome the one, the only Ava DuVernay.
(audience clapping)
Hi Drew.
Oh my gosh, I wanted to talk to you for so long.
I am a long-time admirer
and I'm so, so pleased to meet you.
I can't wait for it to be in person one day.
Oh my goodness, I would totally koala bear
to your eucalyptus tree.
Let's do it one day, I look forward.
Okay, so you have just been
this incredibly prolific storyteller,
but you weren't always a director.
You had other jobs before, you PR, waitressing,
scooping frozen yogurt.
Like what did you like and embrace
or wanna get away from before you became
the huge director that you are today?
Well, you know, the beautiful thing is
I loved all my jobs.
I really, really did.
And I think each one, you know,
prepared me for the next job.
I was a damn good waitress.
And I just feel like if I ever need
to pick up a few extra dollars
or if, hey, this directing thing doesn't work out,
that would probably be,
you can find me in a small town diner, and I was good Drew.
I was a good waitress
because I like to make sure that people were happy,
that they had what they needed, you know?
That they were able to just dine and kick back.
And so I can always waitress if I need to.
Okay, this explains everything that I believed
that I thought I knew about you.
That nurturing really does come through
and it is a choice, it's an approach.
And you know, so when you started out,
you know, this particular part of your journey,
Oprah, if she isn't the person who sort of nurtured,
guided us and mentored us all towards the brilliant
of the aha moment.
And I wanted to ask you something about Oprah's advice,
because I think it applies so much
to the modern world today.
She spoke to something about a critique or a review
that you got for a project you were working on
and she walked you through it.
The reason I wanted to ask you
was because I feel like this applies so much
to people on social media and comments.
Can you tell me about that?
Yeah, it was that it was a review that I got
for one of my early films
that was kind of particularly nasty.
Like, you know not someone critiquing the craft,
but kind of, you know, being a little mean for no reason.
And it hurt my feelings and I was talking with her about it
and I'm blubbering on and on and on.
And I'm on minute five and minute 10
about how it makes me feel
and at the end it was very quiet.
She said, "Do you know this person?"
And I said, "Well no."
And she said "And do they know you personally?"
And I was like, "No", she said "So why does it matter?"
And I thought, "Wow, I don't even know this person."
Like, I didn't even know what the person looked like.
I just had read the words and they hurt.
And so it's really kind of bifurcating
and separating words from feeling, from people.
And really the whole thing gets down to, what do you value?
Do I value these words from what ghost on a page
who I don't know?
Or do I value my experience making that thing,
how much I loved it, all the love that I put into it
and the people who were receiving it
in the way that I intended,
which was a lot of people?
But you know, you always focus on the negative thing.
You could be in a room with everyone smiling
and most people are looking at the one person
who doesn't like, you know, the spinach dip.
Like "Why don't they like it? Everyone else likes it?"
(Drew laughing)
It's so true.
And that's just
human nature.
Exactly.
You gotta work to dismantle it within yourself.
Oh, that is such rich, brilliant advice
and we can all use it because it's true.
And we can apply it to social media.
And we are seeing people be affected by comments,
that person hurt your feelings, we are human beings.
So if you can separate, "Yes, I am a human
and this makes me feel a certain way",
but to take the Oprah advice of, "Do you know this person?
Do they know you?"
And start to untangle yourself from the web of pain
is just so brilliant.
And we all need that in this world, so thank you.
(audience clapping)
We need it.
Thank you.
Now, is it true that you've been stuck in an elevator,
not once, not twice, but three times
with three different legends?
I get stuck in elevators with like icons.
It's like my thing, I don't even know what happens,
but it literally, if I'm in the elevator
with someone who's a known person.
I'm like, "Oh, this elevator's gonna stop."
It's happened to me three different times.
Will you tell me with who?
My favorite one, well, two of them were mean
and one of them was really nice.
So I'll tell you the nice one.
So I was stuck in an elevator, I was a publicist
and I was working on a movie
and he looks at me and I say, "Yeah, I'm gonna, I'm gonna
I'm doing the buzzer, I'm trying to get out"
and he's like, "You know, it'll start again when it's time."
I said, "Okay", we're looking at each other,
and he's like "So, tell me about yourself, let's talk."
And we end up talking, it's Tom cruise, okay?
(Drew gasping)
And he was so, so lovely.
And so for maybe five years after that,
I got flowers on my birthday, every,
every birthday from Tom cruise.
And with a little note about, "Hey, how you doing?"
(audience clapping)
Oh my God, I love him so much, now I love him more.
Thank you for being a fly on the wall
in that amazing elevator.
Last question, is it true that you got in an accident
as a fender bender when you were a teen
because of a cute guy?
Yes.
(Drew laughing)
I really liked this boy.
And so I had my first car and I was driving by his house,
as one does and I guess I got lost in him
watering the grass or something
because literally I smashed straight into a parked car.
(Drew laughing)
And cut to this, he ends up being my boyfriend
for quite a while.
But, it started with, you know, a fender bender.
You know you never know how relationships begin.
I love this story.
(upbeat music)